for me for the most marvelous and
wonderful and great things about chess
is the combination I mean I just love
this idea that I could sacrifice my
queen
the Queen the most powerful piece on the
award so that I could smothered make my
opponent ah it's just poetry love the
combination and there's tons and tons
and tons of combinations so the only way
I could possibly try to understand if
there's millions billions trillions of
combinations
I couldn't possibly know them all or or
or keep them all in my head
so I had to make shortcuts and the
shortcuts I made for myself was I
classified that there were three types
of combinations the first and the most
obvious is the checkmating combination
the checkmating combination is the
easiest combination in chess because
guess what you don't have to count how
much stuff you sacrifice at the end of
the day if you're giving checkmate you
could give away everybody except for
that palm that makes the checkmate so
the checkmating combination is the
easiest combination to understand the
second type of combination is the
combination to win material okay so what
black comes down with a screen on b6
captures as pawn on b2 and I trap the
queen and I win the Queen so I do a four
sequence of moves I sacrifice upon oh
that's my bait the guy swallows the bait
now I get to trap the Queen but it cost
me two rooks and upon maybe that's not
the best combination I ever made I was
supposed to win material loss material
but if I trap the Queen for a row
and upon well that combination is a very
good one so the second type of
combination is what I called the
material combination the goal of the
combination was to win material the
third type of combination is the most
difficult it's called a strategic
combination now what's all that about
so the idea in this the strategic
combination is I might sacrifice I for
me I am sacrificing for a specific type
of a goal it might be to make my king my
opponent's king vulnerable it might be
to create a fortress it might be to
sacrifice in exchange which would open
up the position for my pieces so the
strategic combination was the most
difficult and in my notebooks I you know
like whenever I ran across a strategic
combination man and I pasted that up you
right in there I was really really happy
and I thought in terms that my knowledge
is growing because I have the strategic
combination so today we're going to talk
about strategic class a strategic class
okay so what is that about well
combination is actually easy a strategic
strategic idea there's just so many many
many many strategic ideas it's again you
got to use shortcuts you got to use
shortcuts with your strategic ideas and
I started to use my own like kind of
classification system um okay so that's
the backdrop to what I'm about to
present how many of you play 1.d4 oh my
god okay so we're going to do a
different strategic class-d for one deep
for excellent excellent move really and
one of my favorites I originally started
with E for switch to d4 switch to c4 and
switch back to d4
so I like d4 okay so here is a strategic
conundrum for those of you who play d4 I
I'm a confounding sort of fellow I mean
I play the devil's advocate so to speak
and I will play the move
d7 d6 and I will say to you it's your
turn it's simply your turn i play d 6 i
don't reveal anything after I play d6 I
may play a Kings Indian defense with
Knight f6 and g6 I may play a Leningrad
Dutch with f5 I may try to switch the
game to a benoni with c5 or what I'm
about to show so in this position for
those of you who play one d4 how many of
you would play C 4 C 4 ah does anybody
play chess you do understand this is a
chess class right okay so nobody plays
efore everybody plays d4 and after the
first move you don't let you don't play
c4 okay so okay after the move d6
white essentially has a choice of three
moves if there are more than three moves
please let me know choice number one is
to play e4 now you're in the e4 opening
for those of you play d4 you may not
want to be in a perk defense but this is
certainly your first choice and probably
your best move your second choice is to
play C for your queen pawn open it
opening you expand on the Queen side and
your third choice is Knight f3
does anybody have another shorts what's
you another choice yes in the back
by d5 well this proof would basically
cost you a Tempe a tempo after the move
d5 you're not really attacking anything
so that would allow me to implement c6
or the choice I'm about to show you so
this is a strategic class an idea of of
how to handle a black strategy in this
particular case so this about this is
about one of the most basic positions
you can't have if you're a d4 player if
you play one d4 this
gato appear on your radar in your chess
experience in your chest knowledge c4
because when you play d4 you're usually
trying nine times out of ten to play c4
okay so now what I did and have done and
have played virtually my whole career is
the move e7 e five okay so now this is a
this is a strategic battle a strategic
idea for black what I'm trying to do
with black is I accept the fact that you
as white start the game and you have an
advantage so I am with this move I am
trying to neutralize your advantage
by offering you a trade of Queens okay
so imagine for yourselves you are all
playing the white pieces how many of you
would capture the pawn with D takes e5
d take c5 d takes e5 and how many of you
would trade Queens not a single one yeah
nobody plays chess in this earth it was
like okay a three persons the gentleman
a moment ago had offered the move d5 in
this position the move d5 makes more
sense than it did a moment ago but I
still believe that after the move d5
Black has won not equality but in
advantage I already like blacks position
after the move d5 why because you've
wasted a tempo simply split after the
move
f7 f5 let's just take a look I have 1 2
3 and play you have 1 2 this pawn to
this pawn to you control for I control
for but in my mind's eye I can see that
once I play Knight f6 Bishop e7 castles
I've got this control of the center my
pawns are going to be very dynamic the
likelihood is you're going to be
castling short in other words when
you've played the move d5 it's very less
likely that you're going that way when
your king is going that way guess what
I'm going to have a welcoming committee
for your king okay so after the move e5
again this is a strategic class so the
strategy that we're trying to understand
for this class is a little bit awkward I
strongly believe I think it's a very
very good idea for you to castle
I think castling is really good that
when you castle not only do you usually
we hope bring your king into safety but
you managed to bring a rook that's
sitting in the corner completely
unemployed doing nothing into play when
you have captured Queens traded Queens
you have cost black the right to castle
you robbed him of a very important right
and the King also sits vulnerable on the
open file and it encourages a rook is
going to come to an open file anyway
that's because open files are magnets
for our rook we want our rooks on open
file if our King is sitting on the end
of the open file it obviously is going
to get the attention of the rook so
having said all of that I'll just take a
poll since none of you play chat
throughout take a poll how many of you
like White's position how many of you
like blacks position so it's even-steven
perfect and that's the way I wanted to
explain backwards going backwards into
this concept you're white you have the
opening move you have the advantage I'm
trying to neutralize your advantage so
as you've indicated in the poll most of
you think that black has done that but
why why what why should black have
equalized at all he's proud of his King
on an open file he's lost the right to
castle so why isn't white simply better
after let's say the move Knight c3 I'm
going to develop ok I developed my
knight
so what should black now be doing c7 c6
this is a very good move so what's the
idea behind this move and again this
whole class is about strategy and
strategizing and trying to understand
the battle of ideas because that's what
strategy is to me
so with this bouff c7 c6 black a plaza
the gives himself a big big pat on the
back because he thinks and sees that
this move really fits into the position
on the one hand when I brought my Knight
to c3
there was a consideration that this
night could potentially jump to these
two squares so with the move c6 you're
trying to contain the knight which is
excellent deeper point in that this move
has a second point the deeper point is
black is going to is visualize and
vision pardon me that there's going to
be a mighty rook check on the default
d-line and so black is trying to
construct a cave for his King he
imagines that once the rook comes with
check the king will go to c7 and it will
be safe so the move c7 c6 is an
excellent move now the switch flips now
we've got to imagine what white is
thinking why does thinking that he
really liked to develop his army quickly
as he could but he envisions that for
example Bishop g5 check f6
castles check what could be sweeter to
chicks in a row we're on a roll and the
music stops the bishop on g5 is under
attack the bishop on g5 will have to
move and I don't see any particular
reason why white should be happy about
this position so we're going to go back
and we're going to plot black for his
move c7 c6 and we're going to take it a
little bit deeper and say okay I know
you want to bring your King to c7 how on
earth how on earth can i disturb that
plan how could I do that anybody have a
suggestion
exactly f4 brilliant now again this is
the battle of idea strategic ideas this
is what the class is all about now in my
mind's eye I'm let's say I'm playing the
white pieces I'm really hoping that you
will capture my pawn
when you capture my pawn the first thing
that is happening after you capture my
pawn is you're moving a unit that's
already moved for the second time and
helping me develop so I've just gone one
two three
you've gone one two a moment ago it was
one two three one two in your favor
that's flit thank you for trading pawns
that's the first thing the second thing
that's going on in my mind I'm white is
that after I have castled I'll put you
in check and your king will not have
sanctuary on the c6 c7 square I beg I
beg your pardon
okay this is all really really wonderful
this is great stuff I love this okay so
you know Bobby Fischer famously said
get squares you got to give them I've
done something I've made the strategic
operation to rob you of a good square
for your King but it's coming to cost
right my structure my structure isn't as
good as it once was
in fact I now have an isolated pawn and
I have one island two three islands
versus two so for the sake of fast
development I have sacrificed pawn
structure but I've done it for a very
specific purpose
I want to attack your king does black
have a good move here what what move
should black play a week pardon
black have a good move hit I can well
let's imagine that black develops his
Bishop Bishop to e6
we've always been wanting to do this
ever since the black King has appeared
on the D file we're going to cancel a
check the knight comes to d7 and now
white white to move white to move and
CAC white to move so first of all we go
one two three four five one two three
four
so we pat ourselves on the back of her
white because we have an edge in
development when we have an edge in
development it's really vital it's
incumbent upon us that we maintain that
edge and that we continue in hyper
aggressive mode we've got it we got to
punish black for his sins of losing the
right to castle so let's imagine moves
that could punish black for a moment one
move we notice that we are leaving this
mean that we are not leaving but rather
that this bishop on e6
tax this pawn on c4 so one move that
definitely grabs our attention is the
move Knight of three because in our
minds eye we think that this pawn is no
longer vulnerable I could do a little
combinati on and I could end up with
Bishop and Knight versus rook and pawn
that's one option and I think this
option favors white very much
the second option is I could jump with
my Knight to e5 with a double attack I'm
threatening army escape then do that
right I'm threatening this Bishop over
here oops
and I'm threatening to play rook take d7
down here if that precipitated the
retreat for me Bishop e6 well I have
another combination yes you met
correctamundo
brilliant rook takes d7 Bishop takes d7
Knight boots stop that Knight takes f7
checking hearing Knight takes now
although this knight in the corner is
trapped the reality is it's going to
take you a few moves to capture it I'll
probably end up getting a pawn for it as
well but this position is what white
wanted what white wanted to achieve he
has he's managed to break open the
position when you're behind in
development one of the worst things you
can do is if you're tempted by a pond
you're tempted to grab a pond don't grab
the pawn because it will increase your
opponent's development so we go Knight
f3 okay now with this move Knight f3
we're offering as bait this pawn on c4
but we have other ideas for white here
as well other ideas include the move
Knight
g5 so let's make a move for black pardon
me let's make a move for black let's
play a move like Knight of 6 for example
Knight to g5 attacking the bishop now
let's say black says okay I'm ready to
take your pawn bishop takes c4 c4 again
you know the battle of ideas if it's my
turn I want to take your bishop
if you're not looking if you're not
careful I want to take your pawn on f7
forking your king and rook and also I
have ideas of 'if I've an e6 in the
position so for example let's just say
let's just continue the line with moves
like Bishop takes f1 rook takes f1 let's
say black moves his King oops that
didn't work moves his King to protect
his pawn on f7 well again when you're
ahead in material when you're ahead in
development boo-boo-boo-boo last open
the position play to open the position
that's the entire idea of being ahead
and development is to open up the
position after move for example like e5
doesn't matter where ever this night
goes we have one goal in mind which is
to blast open the position with a six
and let's just say let's just play a few
moves further let's help black out for
just a moment so we give him a chance to
enjoy his predicament so at the end of
this series of moves White has basically
developed his entire army Black's King
is essentially on open Highway rooks are
coming and the two rooks haven't even
gotten out of the corner yet so this
position obviously is really in White's
favor so we go back here for a moment
here
here ah what did we do I thought we had
this position I thought we went do night
that was from 96 that was why we played
the move Knight d7 so knight c6 turns
out to be a false trail and we play
Knight d7 now in this position it's kind
of similar to some of the things that we
were just looking at how many of you
would like to play f4 nonetheless a 4-1
maybe two okay so f4 is a consideration
so let's just take a look at the move F
for a second so again in basic
strategies in in the openings oftentimes
you see this upon tension you see these
captures so you always have to be very
reluctant very very reluctant to capture
a piece or a pawn of your permanent that
develops their pieces so in other words
this move e5 takes f4 Bishop takes f4 I
don't want to play on basic principles
on basic grounds that I'm helping my
opponent develop when I play such a move
so I don't want to capture the pawn on
f4 maybe I'm forced to but I don't want
to do it so I'm looking for other moves
before I would do that then I say oh my
gosh oh my gosh
yessir be careful remove f4 f5 threatens
to trap the bishop is there any way that
I can make a useful move that protects
the threat so yes I can I can play f7 f6
so I can step back with my Bishop and I
leave it up to my opponent to decide now
my opponent
he's probably I would imagine thinking
the same way as me that I don't want to
make a trade
that is going to enhance my opponent's
pieces so in this particular position
imagine that white made this capture and
I recaptured with the knight now a
moment ago that Knight was on d7
bothering nobody
the next thing you know he got issued an
invitation to come to the center of the
board and put pressure upon my pawn
well if I were white I wouldn't want to
make that capture if I were white I
would want to make the move Knight f3
I'd want to make the move fi the
consideration probably those would be my
two major moves and now it's important
now this is an important moment let's
imagine my opponent plays the move
Bishop e3 okay
so again just a battle of ideas now this
is important a moment ago I would never
capture that pawn on f4 because it just
helps white develop his bishop now that
the bishops already developed that's one
of the first things I look at what a
flip huh what a switch a moment ago it
was with a tempo now suddenly it's a key
consideration
why because I'm reckoning that after I
capture and he captures I've isolated as
pawns I've got an e5 square wait a
minute I'm greedy
hey man I'm greedy if the line of
reasoning I've just been mentioning I
don't capture on f4 how about the move
Bishop c5 right doesn't that get our
attention I get our juices flowing Mike
after Bishop c5 if he has forced to
trade the trade favors black oops
small problem I haven't paid enough
attention to my e5 pawn
a small problem this would be the great
move this would be a move that I would
really want to do trade Bishop's bring
my knight to a more powerful square but
as I am about to show and i know i can
do castles with check that's good as
well is that this pawn on e5 is now
vulnerable if it forces me to play the
move Knight d7 I'd like to take back my
entire move with Bishop c5 okay so we're
going to go f4 f6 oops
that wasn't right right okay so Bishop
e3 okay so idea number one I first take
a look at this pawn takes Bishop takes
and I try to figure out is that a good
move possibility number two candidate
number two I really look at the ship c5
the line we just discovered I find
dismay it forces me away next
possibility how about Knight to h6
Knight h6 okay so with the move Knight
h6 my thinking is that if I could play
my Knight to g4 with the temple against
the bishop if the bishop were to drop
back I could then maybe play Bishop c5
or I could then maybe take take and with
my knight on g4 my knight on d7 I'd have
a nice outpost on e5
okay see how this ideas of strategy come
about I start to think if I play the
move Knight h6 my opponent could maybe
inflict some damage on my pawn structure
he could maybe play the move f5
attacking my bishop
if my bishop were to drop back I'd have
to consider the consequences if Bishop
takes h6 maybe I wouldn't like those
consequences maybe I'd like to live
but if the idea if the idea of night h6
was to come to g4 and to conquer the e5
square is another way of doing it how
about this remember move that I was I
would never consider it a moment ago I
know think of it as a pride as a first
choice so now you play 97 let's just say
just for argument's sake we just move
some pieces around after castles Knight
here I start to think that whoo
wouldn't it be nice to control the e5
square I could also do it another way I
could
oops that's not the move I could take
there you are
take and I could offer the bishop
directly Bishop d6 so many of you might
say well wait a minute yes if you allow
white to trade bishops that pawn on d6
could become very vulnerable and that is
true but let's see how vulnerable it
might be so after Bishop takes pawn
takes let's imagine castles and let's
imagine King e7 defending the pawn just
for the moment in my mind's eye I can
conceive that blacks planning to play
the move 95 attacking this pawn on c4
once the knight comes to e5 I could
always defend the pawn with Knight f7
one of the moves that I would really
appreciate white playing would be for
example check this in my opinion would
be strategically a bad error because it
turns out my Kings not honorable at
Aulani 7 the e-file has been closed the
reason one of the reasons that I really
bring this up is this this whole Queen
take D
King takes d8 who benefits the most is
because one of the most topical lines in
chess today is the Berlin Wall how many
of you familiar with the Berlin defense
okay well yeah the well itself I had a
piece at one time by the way
so Vladimir Kramnik almost
single-handedly popularized the Berlin
defense because he was able to wrest the
title away from Garry Kasparov by
playing the black side of this position
so literally the players have nearly
gone from opening to late middle game
early ending with the trade of Queens
and with the trade of a minor piece so
in this position wow this is really
really really different from the
position we were analyzing a moment ago
position we were analyzing a moment ago
there was no double pawn
neither did black have two bishops it
seemed like there were lots of ways for
black to block a potentially
catastrophic check on the D file now
that D file looks really wide open and
yet for all of that this position has
become one of the most popular positions
amongst the most dynamic players in the
world including Hikaru Nakamura
America's number one player Veselin
Topalov when most dynamic players
Bulgaria has ever produced world
champion and of course Magnus Carlsen
has also played this defense so in other
words you are seeing a lot of
grandmasters are making this invitation
to trade queens and to offer to lose the
right to castle to do so as well now
this is a bizarre
our variation the Berlin it's very very
very awkward I think white must be
better but I can tell you that a lot of
players have hit the hit a wall on this
defense including Garry Kasparov because
far off couldn't dent because creme Nix
defenses the funny thing about this
Berlin is at one time after the move
Knight c3 was played everybody everybody
played King e8 and just said ok I'm
awaiting developments tell me white
please what you are going to do today
after the move Knight c3 black does a
whole lot of different stuff one of the
things one of the things he does
including one of the things he does I'm
sorry is to play Bishop d7 and after for
example a move like rook d1 black plays
King c8 so the idea of King c8 is that
he's making a home for his King over
here on the Queen side with b7 b6 so
unlike our first variation where black
was playing the move c6 one tempo
bringing his king to c7 black is now
making one two three to get a safe King
and yet still still people think that
blacks position is fine it's a kind of a
strange strategical question that I'm
posing on you to ask to answer when is a
good to trade Queens
you